قصه ملهمه مليئه بالامل والصبر معا للشابه
السعوديه لمياء محمد التي تم زرع يدين لها
من متبرع عمليه تعد من الحالات النادره
جدا على مستوى العالم وهي الاولى في الشرق
الاوسط والسعوديه بدايه القصه تعود لست
سنوات اي عام 2017 حين اجرت لمياء عمليه
تجميل لشفط الدهون في الرياض لينقلب الامر
عكس ذلك بتاتا فبعد ايام الخروجها من
المشفى اصابها مشكله في كف اليدين ليقرر
الاطباء بعد اربعه اشهر بطره يديها لتسافر
بعدها في رحله علاج للولايات الم تحده
جلست خلالها مده اربع سنوات على امل ايجاد
متبرع ليتحقق الحلم اخيرا وتخضع لعمليه
معقده استغرقت ساعات طويله اشرف عليها
طاقم طبي من عده اطباء
كانت ايام صعبه بس الحمد لله عدت
[موسيقى]
عندي اليد هذه الحمد لله تفتح اوكي لكن
الابهام عندي بسبب الصفقات هنا في الزراعه
شويه مشدود يحتاج عمليه ان شاء الله
بسويها واذهب برضو بسبب الساقات ما تفتح
مره لكن الحمد لله يعني اعتمد على نفسي في
كل شيء تقريبا
على كل من رياض تنضم الينا لمياء محمد
الفتاه التي زرعت لها يدين ومن جده ينضم
الينا المشرف عليها الدكتور ممدوح اهلا بك
وما ابدا معك دكتور ممدوح اهلا بك معنا
يسعد صباحك بصباح العربيه
صباح الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم وسعيد
بتواجدي معاكم عمليه زراعه يدين هي من
العمليات النادره في العالم والاولى من
نوعها في الشرق الاوسط والسعوديه هل لكان
تشرح لنا العمليه اولا ومدى تعقيدها
نعم طبعا احنا لازم نوضح انه هنا في نوعين
من هذه العمليات العمليه الاولى اللي هي
اعاده زراعه الطرف المبتور يعني لا سمح
الله لو شخص اصيب في حادث او لاي سبب حصل
انه انبتر الاصبع او قدم او يد هذه اعاده
البتر او اعاده زراعه العضو هذا شيء موجود
في المملكه من عشره سنوات اكثر ومتواجد في
كل المستشفيات حاله لمياء هي زراعه يدين
من شخص متبرع وهذا الشيء للاسف ما هو
موجود عندنا لانه عندنا زراعه الاعضاء كبد
وكلى والامور هذه منتشره وموجوده لكن
زراعه الاطراف اللي هي اليدين شيء جدا
نادر جدا صعب وتحتاج متبرعين وهذا الشيء
اللي حصل مع الامير في الولايات المتحده
لما سافرت عشان كذا جلست اربع سنوات
تقريبا تنتظر هذه المتبرع انه يحصل لها
زراعه اليدين
احنا كتير يا اهلا وسهلا فيك احنا كتير
كمان حابين نعرف كل هذه التفاصيل متعلقه
بتركيب يدين حقيقيتين لم بالعاده احنا
بنسمع عن اشخاص يتم تركيب اطراف الصناعيه
لهم اذا كانوا بحاجه مثلا لزراعه اطراف
كيف حالفك الحظ بان تحصلي على يدين
حقيقيتين ما القصه
الحمد لله انا في السعوديه عشان كذا حلفني
الحظ هذا اول شيء
طبعا بدعم من
الدكتور ممدوح
واكيد دعم
وزير الصحه سابقا توفيق الربيعه جاني امر
سامي من والدي
الملك سلمان والحمد لله
بخصوص المتبرع يا لمياء طبعا كانت
ايوه بخصوص المتبرعين
هل في مين هذا المتبرع وكيف تم التواصل
اللي اخذ يدين حقيقيتين
لا المستشفى عندهم سياسه انه ما اعرف مين
المتبرع لين وافقون العائله
وكذلك هم اهل المتبرع معي ما المفروض
يعرفون عني اي تفاصيل لين انا اوافق وهذا
الشيء لسه ما صار ما كنت مستعده وقتها
ممكن بعدين ان شاء الله لكل المشاهدين
اللي بيشوفونا وبدهم يفهموا يعني انت
ضليتي اربع سنين في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تنتظرين متبرع وعلى الاستعداد
لاجراء العمليه ما الذي حصل حتى تصلين الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
شو صار شو اللي صار معك لمياء
طبعا انا بعد هنا سنه بعدها جاني الامر
السامي قعدت هناك في امريكا اربع سنين
انتظر لانه كان في يعني فصيله الدم شويه
صعبه والاشياء هذه بس الحمد لله بعد اربع
شهور واربعه اربع سنين واربع شهور واربع
ايام بالضبط يعني متبرع دكتور ممدوح
دكتور اوكي اليوم لما بنحكي احنا عن هكذا
نوع من عمليات كيف بتم تحقيق التوافق وبان
تتلائم
اليدين مثلا الحقيقيتين مع زراعتها في جسد
اخر ومكان اليد الاخرى كيف
نعم هي طبعا بتتم بنفس الطرق اللي بتم
فيها زراعه الكلى مثلا لازم يكون في توافق
دموي بتتعمل تحاليل معينه خاصه بين
الشخصين وبعد الزراعه الشخص لم يلان لازم
تستمر على ادويه مثبطه للمناعه مدى حياتها
لان هي لو توقفت الان عن هذه الادويه
جسمها يرفض لانه حيتعامل مع اليدين هذه
كانها جسم غريب ويتم رفضها مباشره فعشان
كذا الشخص اللي بيتم زراعه اي عضو سواء
يدين او كلى او قلب لازم ياخذ الادويه
المثبته للمناعه هذه مدى الحياه طيب امر
مهم طبعا عشان العمليه معقده وعشان يلاقوا
شخص
معقده ونادره دكتور طيب نرجع للاميه لمياء
اليوم انت موظفه اداريه هل عدتي الى عملك
بشكل طبيعي هل تستخدمين ايديك الاثنين
بشكل طبيعي حدثينا اكثر
الحمد لله ايوه رجعت العمليه في موظفه
اداريه
تقريبا استخدم ايدين في كل شيء الا بعض
الاشياء الدقيقه لسه الاعصاب يعني يبغى
لها توصل
عندي اليد اليسار عندي الابهام لسه ما
يتحرك يحتاج عمليه بس يعني تقريبا الى
الان الحمد لله يعني يعني زي ما تشوفون في
الفيديوهات كيف حركه اليدين اول وكاف
الحين فرق يعني تقريبا 80% يعني وحتى لم
كمان يعني احنا شايفينك مباشره معنا على
الهواء يعني حتى قادرين نشوف الايدين كيف
عم تتحرك والتشابك بين الاصابع للايدين
اليوم كمان لم قد ايه مثلا انت بتشعري انه
اليوم صار في ضروره واهميه انه الناس
تتبرع اذا كان فيها فعلا انقاذ حياه او
مساعده شخص اخر اليوم
فعلا هذا الشيء يعني غير حياتي وغير مو بس
حياتي حياتي العائله اللي حولي كلهم امي
اخواني انت ما تغير حياه شخص بالتبرع انت
تغير حياه عائله كامله
فهذا الشيء لازم يكون يعني من يعني مثلا
عندنا في ناس كثير مبتورين عندنا في الحد
الجنوبي كثير جنود فقدوا اطرافهم يحتاجون
لهذا الشيء
فان شاء الله يكون في عمليه زي كده قريب
في السعوديه ان شاء الله دكتور ممدوح ما
مصير هكذا عمليات نادره ومعقده في منطقتنا
في منطقه شرق الاوسط
لو توفر المتبرعين العمليات هذه ستجرى
بصوره بدون اي مشاكل الحمد لله جميع
جراحيه تجميل والاوعيه الدمويه عندنا
متوفره عندهم التقنيات والمستشفيات متوفره
فيها كل الاجهزه اللي بتساعدنا اننا نقوم
بهذه العمليات لو في متبرعين مباشره
عمليات هادسه تجرى بدون اي مشاكل باذن
الله
بنش
كركم وهذه قصص بطوليه لعرب يفتخر بها شكرا
جزيلكم جزيلا لكم وايضا لم لم بالتوفيق
دائما وبالسلامه لمحمد فتاه التي زرعت لها
يدين وايضا المشرف عليها الدكتور ممدوح
العشي